Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. Carriage on NIFA here series. We often.
Talk about smoke and fluid simulations,
and sometimes the examples showcase the beautiful smoke plume,
but not much else. However, in real production environments,
these simulations often involve complex scenes with many objects that interact
with each other and therein lies the problem computing.
These interactions is called coupling and it is very difficult to get, right,
but it's necessary for many of the scenes you will see throughout this video,
this new graphics paper builds on a technique called the lattice Boltzmann
method and promises a better way to compute this two way.
Coupling for instance, in this simulation two way,
coupling is required to compute how this fire is smoke trail propels,
the rocket upward.
So coupling means interaction between different kinds of objects.
But what about the two-way part? What does that mean? Exactly?
Well, first let's have a look at one way. Coupling as the box moves here,
it has an effect on the smoke plume around it.
This example also showcases one way coupling where the falling plate stirs up
the smoke around it.
The parts with the higher Reynolds numbers showcase more turbulent flows.
Typically that's the real good stuff. If you ask me
and now onto to wake up link in this case, similarly to previous ones,
the boxes are allowed to move the smoke,
but the added two-way coupling part means that now the smoke is
also allowed to blow away the boxes.
What's more the vortices here on the right.
We're even able to suspend the red box in the air for a few seconds,
an excellent demonstration of a beautiful phenomenon.
Now let's look at the previous example with the dropping plate and see what
happens. Yes, indeed. As the play drops,
it moves the smoke and as the smoke moves, it also blows away the boxes.
Whew.
Due to improvements in the coupling computation,
it also simulates these kinds of 40 sees much more realistically than previous
works. Just look at all this magnificent progress in just two years.
So what else can we do with all this?
What are the typical scenarios that require accurate to wake up link? Well,
for instance, it can perform an incredible tornado simulation and you see here,
and there's an alternative view where we only see the objects moving about.
So all this looks good,
but really how do we know how accurate this technique is?
And now comes my favorite part.
And this is when we let reality be our judge and compare the simulation results
with real real-world experiments,
hold onto your papers while you observe the real experiment here on the left.
And now the algorithmic reproduction of the same scene here.
How close are they? Goodness. Very, very close.
I will stop the footage at different times so we can both evaluate it better.
Love it. The technique can also undergo the wind tunnel test.
Here's the real footage and here's the simulation.
And it is truly remarkable how close this is able to match it.
And I was wondering that even though,
as someone who has been doing fluids for a while now,
if someone cropped this part of the image and told me that it is real-world
footage, I would have believed that in a second absolute insanity.
So how much do we have to wait to compute a simulation like this? Well,
great news. It uses your graphics card,
which is typically the case for the moral demand,
very fluid simulation algorithms out there,
but the more elaborate ones typically don't support it,
or at least not without a fair amount of additional effort.
The quickest example was this, as it was simulated in less than six seconds,
which I find to be mind blowing the smoke simulation with box movements in a few
seconds, I am truly out of words.
The rocket launch scene took the longest with 16 hours while the falling
plate example with a strong draft that threw the boxes around with about four
and a half hours of computation time,
the results depend greatly on Delta T, which is the size of the timestamps,
or in other words,
in how small increments we can advanced time when creating these simulations to
make sure we don't miss any important interactions.
You see here that in the rocket example,
we have to simulate roughly a hundred thousand steps for every second of
video footage. No wonder it takes so long.
We have an easier time with this scene where these timestamps can be 50 times
larger without losing any detail. And hence it goes much faster.
The grid resolution also matters a great deal,
which specifies how many spatial points the simulation has to take place in the
higher, the resolution of the grid, the larger the region we can cover.
And the more details we can simulate as most research works,
this technique doesn't come without limitations. However,
it is less accurate if we have simulations involving thin rods and shells,
and typically uses two to three times more memory than a typical simulator
program. If these are the only trade-offs to create all this marvelous footage,
sign me up this very second. Overall,
this paper is extraordinarily well-written and of course it has been accepted to
the SIGGRAPH conference.
One of the most prestigious scientific venues in computer graphics, research,
huge congratulations to the authors.
And if you wish to see something beautiful today,
make sure to have a look at the paper itself in the video description,
truly stunning work, what a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Lambda GPU cloud.
If you're for inexpensive cloud GPU's for AI,
check out Lambda GPU cloud they've recently launched Quadro RTX
6,000 RTX 8,000 and V 100 instances and
hold onto your papers because Lambda GPU cloud can cost less than half of
AWS and Asia.
Plus they are the only cloud service with 48 gigabyte RTX eight thousands.
Join researchers at organizations like apple, MIT,
and Caltech in using Lambda cloud instances, workstations or servers,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for their longstanding support and for helping us make
better videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.